cyberpunk 2077 has been delayed again we
now have a better idea of the size and
scale of spider-man Miles Morales and
Sony has just trademark their newest
slogan for the duel since I'm Persia and
you've reached your safe date for
Thursday June 18 cyberpunk 2077
announced this morning if he had Twitter
that the game is getting delayed until
November 19th in their statement they
said the game has finished both gameplay
and content wise but with such an
abundance of content and complex systems
interweaving with each other we need to
properly go through everything balance
game mechanics and fix a lot of bugs
we'll hear more on June 25th during the
games at night city wire stream and to
be honest in a world where a lot of
games experience technical difficulties
and bugs at launch I really don't mind
waiting a couple more months to make
sure it's perfect
is it an expansion or is it not an
expansion that was the question for a
lot of spider-man Miles Morales fans
after there were some conflicting
reports when the game was revealed
insomniac has now clarified by saying if
you want to compare it to something then
look no further than Uncharted The Lost
Legacy while The Lost Legacy was a
shorter adventure that was a part of the
main series it's substantially larger
than other standalone spin-offs like
infamous first light
insomniac also said it's a new story
with a new set pieces fresh villains and
unique quests New York will also look
different because it's set in winter and
Harlan is covered in snow of course rate
racing improved models and reworked hair
animation is also a hot topic but it's
important to keep in mind that miles is
still learning from Peter so he's gonna
feel different to play and he's gonna
have some other cool abilities like
electrified punches and going and
visible insomniac says Peters story
isn't over though but this game is all
focused on miles
spider-man Miles Morales is coming out
this holiday season
I am really looking forward to seeing
how not only the game plays but how new
features in these next-gen consoles are
gonna make the game feel which leads us
to our next topic
PS 5s new controller is called the dual
Sims and Sony has just trademarked
heighten your senses as the slogan for
it
this likely references the haptic
feedback on the controller which will
allow you to feel things like the
tension tightening when you draw a bow
or the rushing and rumbling of
approaching enemies it also has the
light bar and speaker like the ps4
controller which means the only other
senses left or taste and smell right
maybe that'll be PS 6 you might notice
we are live a little bit earlier today
but that's because we wanted to give you
the heads-up but EA play is happening
this afternoon and as a part of play for
all we're gonna be streaming it right
here on GameSpot if you don't know what
play for all is well it's our multi week
charity event that we've been putting
together to raise money for black lives
matters and code that 19 relief efforts
we've already played a ton of games and
had so much fun and a lot of really
insightful interviews with people are
ready across the industry but we aren't
done yet and thanks to you guys
and if you've been tuning in every day
between 12:00 p.m. and 2:00 p.m. Pacific
time then you would have seen that we've
already raised thousands of dollars
thanks to you guys so let's keep going
strong and let's keep having fun all
right you guys that's all for the news
for today thank you so much for tuning
in you can give me a follow on twitter
at persia underscore XO and of course
make sure you reach your next days date
on Monday with kirt see you next time
[Music]
[Music]